at least 40 people have been killed in
an attack on a school in Western Uganda
this happened in pondway that's a few
kilometers from the border with the
Democratic Republic of Congo the police
say dormitory was set on fire by
fighters from the Allied Democratic
forces the ADF the Army says it is
pursuing the attackers to rescue those
who were abducted Catherine soy is
following developments from the Kenyan
Capital Nairobi uh Catherine it's so
good to talk to you what more have you
been able to find out about all of this
who was abducted and where they might
have been taken
yeah we have been talking to journalists
who are on the ground we have also
spoken uh to an administrator a
government administrator who confirmed
that around 40 people 40 students were
killed and what we know right now is
that soldiers uh
Ugandan soldiers are currently pursuing
uh these attackers into a varunga
national park in the Democratic Republic
of Congo we also know that they fled
there we also know that there's a
dormitory that was burned down and a
food store that was looted as well now
we have been told by police that that
whole area the school itself has been
cordoned off so it's a very much
developing uh story but people there are
very afraid and there's a lot of anxiety
and you know there's it's death so
people are very very afraid and
uncertain about what's going to happen
next
what can you tell us about this border
area between Uganda and the Democratic
Republic of Congo also that poses a
specific challenge for the Ugandan
forces if they have to cross the border
to pursue uh the attackers what can you
tell us about that too
yes this is a very big uh attack and
everybody is talking about it because
it's a you know it's a cross-border
account County uh it's not it's a
cross-border
um happenings uh we have people in their
sea and people are in
um people in
Uganda uh trading and things like that
but then we have seen other attacks
um in recent past for example we have uh
ugandans who have been killed and
assassinated by ADF and in 2021 there
was a suicide attack that happened in
Kampala the capital and that's why the
government sent troops into a DRC to
help DRC forces to deal with uh ADF now
ADF itself is uh is based in um Benny
territory in North kivu Province but
then we also see a lot of attacks even
with the presence of these troops and
U.N peacekeepers as well we see this
bracelet Brazen attacks by uh ADF
thousands of people in the ERC itself
have been killed many are displaced and
now that we're seeing uh this you know
attack in
Uganda itself people are very worried
and very anxious about what's going on
Catherine soy reporting on this from
Nairobi thank you very much let's bring
in Danielle guambale he is a lawyer and
expert on government Affairs he joins us
from Kampala Daniel first your thoughts
on this attack
um thank you so much the attack is
[Music]
um
Jihadi outfits disorganized
the masses
keep some targets running back to best
if you're lucky enough actionable
intelligence hit the best way
the soldiers are but as far as I'm
concerned the updf is almost overview
represented in that area they are great
Barracks within a radius of five
kilometers from that school in fact two
of the parts of the epdf are one
kilometer away from the school
um we also know that the actual number
is 42 and the girls were bludgeoned with
and blank instruments and the boys were
really banned in the dormitory we also
know that
a general a commanding officer of the
mountain division or imposed territory
in the attack took place has confirmed
that they had entered
showing that the EDF had been in the
place for two days
um which shows probably in lapse in
synthetics and actually and they are
working on the internet so that the UTV
has received
um the epdf has enough assets within
that area
to mount a rhombus comeback or even a
counter attack they have a man aerial
Vehicles they have attackers they have
Emirates there's no reason why this
attack should have taken place at the
time it took place and right according
to still all and some adults would have
been killed in the money
do the Ugandan forces have the Personnel
the resources the know-how necessary to
pursue
the group that carried out the attack if
need be in DRC
so um
by soldiers in the southern sections of
kivo under the East African
reaction force we have at least 5000 in
the north cable and the operation
shooter shoulder means here pursuing The
Indian in fact some analysts believe the
agf is coming into Uganda because of how
much pressure they are under emergency
their air assets available
and most definitely enough Personnel to
pursue the area of this to me was the
baby clubs in actioning or working on
the interview forces and received it's a
big issue right now because this shows
just recently were attacked in Somalia
and still at least think we didn't act
on the internet very well so
[Music]
I think there's a lapse in Italian so
March 31st it was reported in one of the
daily papers that the direct transition
from the internal security organization
left and Kano Emmanuel katawazi had won
his officers along the border with the
DRC to be on high alert and then just
two weeks later we get this attack
there's also confirmation from the
commanding officer all right he knew
that for two days
the air force them
Daniel boombale thank you so much for
joining us on the program today we
appreciate your insights on this